I mean,
there's a lot of debate in the
scientific literature about the meaning
of dreams and perhaps there's even
debate about whether it's possible for
dreams to have meaning.
I think partly the debate exists because
to do dream analysis properly,
as union particular pointed out,
uh,
you need a vast body of knowledge in the
dream interpreter about comparative
mythology and ritual and symbol and,
and art history and so forth because
dreams of course use images as their
primary means of conceptualization now
in order to understand what,
what dreams mean and how they can be
useful in therapy apart from
appreciating the fact that the
interpreter needs a broad body of
knowledge that scientists generally
don't develop.
It's also important to know what it is
that scientists have discovered about
dreams.
So for example,
we know that dreams occur during rapid
eye movement sleep.
You cycle into rapid eye movement.
Sleep about every 90 minutes when you're
asleep,
when you're in rapid eye movement,
sleep,
your motor centers.
So your action centers are very much
activated in your brain,
but your body is paralyzed so that you
can't move around.
Um,
your eyes are moving because of course
it doesn't really matter if your eyes
move while you're asleep because they
won't take you anywhere,
but if your legs were moving while you
were asleep,
you run into walls while you were
dreaming and scientists have actually
managed to damage the motor inhibition
systems in cats so that they do move
around when they're dreaming anyways.
If you wake up when someone's dreaming,
their brain is about as active as it is
when they're awake,
so there's a tremendous amount of neural
processing going on in the dream state.
If you wake someone up when they're
dreaming,
there's about an 80 percent chance that
they'll report the emotion of anxiety.
Dreams tend to focus on threat
processing.
Now,
a threat is anything that might hurt
you,
but it's more than that to a threat is
anything that doesn't fit into your
current conceptual scheme.
So imagine that you have a theory about
the way the world is and then you act on
that theory and sometimes things work
out the way you'd like them to work out,
but often they don't.
And every time things work out in a way
that isn't how you would like or how you
predicted that indicates that there's
some more about the world that you have
to learn about and that fact first
manifests itself in anxiety.
Now the dream focuses on anxiety and
then it loosens up.
It's the normal conceptual constraints
that characterize waking thinking and it
starts to play in a sense or hypothesize
about how your current categorical
structure could be shifted around so
that that threat could be accounted for.
Okay?
Now that means the dream is dealing with
things that you need to understand,
but you don't yet understand.
So when you wake up and you remember the
dream,
the dream doesn't really make sense
because it's about something you don't
understand.
Now it's your brain's best guess at
configuring or understanding the
unknowable,
but it's like it's like the first layer
of a multilayered process,
which eventually would culminate in
fully developed thought maybe over
months or maybe over years,
or maybe you would never manage it at
all.
The unknown thing or the threat is just
too great to really come to any terms
with it whatsoever.
Okay?
Now imagine that you're dreaming about
something and it produces enough emotion
with the threat produces enough emotion,
not only to produce a very vivid dream,
but to wake you up.
When you wake up,
you remember the dream and then you go
to someone about it.
Well,
the dream is about something you don't
yet understand that it's upsetting and
if you tell a bunch of people about it,
they're going to give you all sorts of
opinions on the dream and that's a way
that you can gather more information
about the threat,
which is known as a nightmare.
Perhaps Cynthia dream,
which is troubling,
all puzzling because it's so abstract.
Could you differentiate?
I think
it's clearer in the case of nightmares
and often too,
because nightmares tend to have
archetipal themes.
You know,
people for example,
are often threatened by monsters at
night and a monster is a Chi Mira that's
made up of the different parts of
different parts of frightening thing.
A dragon is a camera,
for example,
because it's made out of reptilian parts
and it also includes the idea of fire in
transformation,
so a nightmare is that a dream that
tends to use archetipal imagery to
conceptualize a fairly powerful threat
and if you recounted nightmare to a
person with no specific training,
they're going to have some opinion about
it and their opinion might be useful in
terms of information,
Katherine,
but if you recount a dream to someone
who's psychologically trained and his
also symbolically trained and who has,
you know,
great,
great depth of knowledge with regards to
the structure of religious thinking and
and comparative literature.
The light that they're going to shed on
your dream is much greater and more
profound and sometimes a,
a dream interpretation can offer the
person who's had the dream a leap
forward in knowledge that might've taken
them five or six years to conceptualize
by themselves.
No ordinarily have had.
Because the person who's the expert
who's had the dream recounted to them
knows and says,
Oh yes,
I know of that place that they say the
theme to that experience.
They've had that symbol and it's meaning
and a bubble what it feels like because
of surely it is,
um,
some people say that me included,
I'm that one way to interpret a dream
when you wake up is to just like you
would taste a sip of wine,
just hold the flavor and,
and hold the feeling.
What does it feel like and what does
feel,
what feels the same in your real life?
And that's what the dream is trying to
tell you with a collage of singles and
memories as well that is drawn on in
recent.
I'm conscious,
uh,
experience to try and put it together.
Hence the dream can be very abstract.
Would you say that's the case?
Sometimes
I think there's two things are really
worth highlighting in the first is the
category is that a dream uses are
generally based on emotional similarity
rather than logical similarity?
Yes.
So a dream for example,
might represent fear or the fear of
something unknown by using a
juxtaposition of a variety of images of
frightening thing.
So imagine that in the dream world,
the basic rule is all things that
produced the same emotion are the same
thing,
and so you're a description of a dream
interpretation process that relies on
identifying similarities in emotional
state,
gets right to the core of how dream
thought works.
Now secondarily,
I also believe that if you are able to
help someone,
a construct at dream interpretation that
fits there also able to feel that it
fits,
it clicks or it makes sense or it's like
the punchline of a joke in some way they
can tell that the interpretation have,
uh,
put some missing pieces of the puzzle
into place.
And I think it's important to rely on
that as an indicator of whether the
interpretation is actually derived from
the dream or sort of just at a
theoretical imposition on its structure.
Now we can go underneath that too.
And I mentioned already that basic
categories are more action oriented than
object oriented.
So basic categories,
the basic categories of the human mind
are categories to do things with.
Well,
by the same token,
there are also motivational and
emotional categories.
So the primordial mind,
like the animal mind thinks sort of
axiomatically that all things that
produced the same are the same thing.
So there's things that make you happy or
there's things that make you sad or
there's things that make you anxious and
the fact that all those things share the
capacity to evoke that emotion speaks of
some essential essential identity
between them.
Now the identity is in relationship to
the experiencer and not necessarily with
regards to similarity between the
objects,
but it's still how we naturally think.
And it's certainly how mythologies
thinks and it's how drama thinks and how
religion things.
We've lost sight of that in part because
we've become scientifically trained to
some degree and we tend to believe that
the real categories of the world are
objective and,
uh,
that,
that just strikes me as it's wrong.
There's something about it that's wrong
and it's wrong because we have to act.